Electrophilic aromatic substitution is a
reaction that replaces one of the
hydrogen atoms on benzene with a group.
Before we show the arrow pushing
mechanism, let's dive into the reaction
flask and see what's going on in there.
When benzene and bromine are mixed
they'll move around in solution by
diffusion, sometimes bumping into each
other.  But these molecular collisions are
not going to be productive; they won't
cause a reaction. Bromine is simply not
powerful enough—not positive enough—to
make benzene react with it. However; if we
add in an iron catalyst this can
associate with the bromine, building up
positive charge on it. Now, when benzene
bumps into this activated bromine
species it can react. One of the double
bonds become shared in a new bond with
bromine and forms a carbocation on
benzene. Now, one of the bromine atoms can
dissociate from the iron complex leaving
as Br minus. This deprotonates the
molecule, neutralizes the carbocation,
and forms bromobenzene. Now let's show
this mechanism with conventional arrow
pushing. Benzene uses its double bond to
attack activated bromine and the Br
minus that's displaced forms a new bond
with iron. Now the drive for this
compound to become aromatic again is so
great that we can show a spontaneous
deprotonation and just write minus H+
under the arrow. This reaction is
general, so anytime benzene encounters an
electrophile that is powerful enough
it'll open up its double bond attacking
it. We can then show the electrons
pushing back into the ring and if we'd
like and have an appropriate conjugate
base in solution we can use that to do a
deprotonation. This gives us our
substituted aromatic ring. Now that we've
looked at the general electrophilic
aromatic substitution mechanism let's
look at the possible electrophiles that
we can add to an aromatic ring. We
already saw the addition of bromine and
equivalents of Cl+
can also be used to react benzene. This
reaction is halogenation. The nitronium
ion can react with benzene in the
nitration reaction. This gives a nitro
derivative. Sulfonation of benzene can
be accomplished using sulfur trioxide in
a solution of sulfuric acid. The
acylium ion, shown here, can also be
attacked by benzene. This ion has
resonance with a carbocation that makes
it more obvious how benzene will attack.
The reaction results in the addition of
an acyl group to benzene and it's called
Friedel-Crafts alkylation. Finally some
benzene derivatives can react with carbocations .
This reaction gives alkylated
derivatives and is called Friedel-Crafts
alkylation.
Benzene is a relatively stable molecule
However, when it encounters a powerful enough
electrophile
It will undergo
electrophilic aromatic substitution.
We've also seen the five major benzene
derivatives that we can form by reactions with
different electrophiles.
But we haven't yet looked at how those
electrophiles are made,
and the conditions under which these reactions
occur. We'll do that in a specific
lesson for each reaction.
Thanks for watching!